an annual event held by the UN nuclear
Watchdog at its headquarters
this year over 2 500 participants from
175 member states director General
Rafael Grossi opened the session
highlighting the organization's main
objective to maintain nuclear safety
across the world
now more critical than ever given
historic events such as Russia's
invasion of Ukraine is the root cause
and that led to this heated debate on
Thursday when Canada and Poland
spearheaded a joint statement on behalf
of 50 delegates in which they call on
the Russian Federation to seize all
activities at the Zappa region nuclear
power plant immediately
the iea's latest report on safety
concerns around the zapparesia nuclear
plant delivered in September raised
serious concerns about a possible
nuclear disaster if the military
activities continue around the plant
the agency has passed two resolutions
this year calling on all parties to
cease military activities near the plant
Russia's ambassador to the agency
insists his country has no military
Presence at the plant but rather
National Guards and blamed Ukraine for
continuing to attack Europe's largest
nuclear power plant Ambassador Mikhail
ulyanov also called Ukraine's proposal
for a demilitarized zone around the
plant an unrealistic demand
I will not comment on the speech of the
representative of Russia I will only say
that everything he said is a complete
lie Iran's nuclear program was in the
spotlight as the head of Iran's atomic
energy agency delivered the opening
speech at the conference Muhammad islami
stressed the need for sanctions relief
before return to the 2015 nuclear deal
which saw Tehran limit its nuclear
program
islami held two rounds of talks with
director General Grossi privately on the
sidelines at the conference the first
such meetings between the two men since
June
iaea's latest report on Iran indicates
the agency is no longer able to provide
reassurances that Iran's nuclear program
is entirely peaceful
as a conference draws to a close a
number of resolutions have passed one
urging the Democratic People's Republic
of Korea to abide by the safeguards of
the non-proliferation treaty another one
on nuclear safety in the Middle East
calling on all those countries to extend
their full cooperation to the director
General so he can do his job which is to
ensure non-proliferation whether These
Warnings will have the desired outcome
remains to be seen
dorsa chapari Al Jazeera Vienna